[Música]
al menos siete víctimas fatales deja la
jornada de represión más fuerte hasta
ahora contra las protestas ciudadanas en
mianmar también se reportan en varios
heridos de bala y centenares de
detenidos cuando el país cumple un mes
de protestas contra el golpe de estado
del pasado primero de febrero
la agencia de alimentos y medicamentos
de eeuu aprobó el uso de emergencia de
la vacuna de una sola dosis contra el
cob y 19 desarrollada por johnson y
johnson se trata del tercer fármaco
aprobado en el país y el presidente joe
biden ya confirmó un primer acuerdo por
cuatro millones de unidades
multitudinarias protestas en varias
ciudades de argentina en contra del
escándalo de las vacunas vi haití que ha
empañado la campaña de inmunización en
el país esto tras conocerse que
funcionarios y personalidades cercanas
al gobierno se vacunaron estime respetar
los turnos establecidos
bienvenidos a una nueva mañana de
información de américa latina y del
mundo aquí en 224 mi nombre es liliana
valencia iniciamos en mianmar donde las
fuerzas militares han intensificado sus
esfuerzos por reprimir las protestas en
contra del golpe de estado militar de
principios de mes la policía ha
disparado contra los manifestantes con
munición reales según los informes
dejando al menos siete fallecidos
decenas de heridos y arrestos masivos el
país está sumido en el caos desde la
toma del poder por parte de los
militares y la detención de la líder
nacional and sanssouci que puso fin a
los tímidos pasos hacia la democracia en
el país
ya sean escudos metálicos hechos a mano
con la palabra people o palos de bambú
paraguas cubos de basura llenos de
ladrillos estas improvisadas barricadas
callejeras para impedir el avance de las
fuerzas de seguridad están repartidas
por todo mi al mar en rangún miles de
manifestantes a favor de la democracia
siguieron en las calles a pesar de la
intensificación de la represión por
parte de las fuerzas militares cuando se
va a cumplir un mes del golpe de
estado-militar la policía elevó la
represión recurriendo a tácticas más
violentas mientras los militares
intentan disolver las protestas en todo
el país pese al uso de la fuerza letal y
las detenciones masivas
los manifestantes firma nos dicen que no
las disuadirá nos enfrentamos a muchas
medidas represivas en todo el país pero
aún así la gente salió a protestar de
nuevo sin miedo incluso los guardias
forestales se están uniendo al
movimiento y la junta está actuando
ilegalmente por lo que los ciudadanos
deben protegerse
y un desafío en números que también se
vio a prueba durante los disturbios en
dawei los medios locales de la ciudad
sureña informaron de que tres
manifestantes murieron por disparos de
munición real y otros fueron heridos con
balas de goma la última jornada de
protestas deja al menos siete muertos en
todo el país los ciudadanos birmanos se
han organizado contra el golpe militar
del 1 de febrero pidiendo la vuelta a la
democracia y la liberación de la líder
gubernamental detenida en sal succi
eeuu aprobó el uso de una tercera vacuna
contra el cob y 19 el fármaco de una
sola dosis desarrollado por johnson y
johnson recibió luz verde de la agencia
de alimentos y medicamentos el gobierno
del presidente joe biden y la
multinacional estadounidense afirmaron
ya de tener un acuerdo por la compra de
4 millones de dosis para letales en este
informe de marrón
era sólo cuestión de tiempo los primeros
lotes de las vacunas desarrolladas por
johnson y johnson ya viajan hacia eeuu
la agencia de alimentos y medicamentos
aprobó su uso de emergencia y se espera
que el fármaco empiece a distribuirse
durante los próximos días la
autorización de esta vacuna expande la
disponibilidad de vacunas el mejor
método de prevención médico contra el
kobe 19 para ayudarnos a luchar contra
la pandemia
y es que eeuu necesita toda la ayuda
posible esta semana el país superó el
medio millón de muertos por la pandemia
la vacuna de johnson y johnson se
convierte en la tercera probada en suelo
estadounidense los fármacos de facer y
modernas ya se están administrando entre
la población
desde que empezó la campaña de
vacunación el 14 de diciembre se han
inyectado 70 53 millones de dosis de las
cuales casi 54 millones se inocularon
durante 38 días de administración by
then
el presidente demócrata prometió 100
millones de dosis en sus primeros 100
días de gobierno hasta la fecha está
superando su propio objetivo
en total un 14% de la población
estadounidense ha recibido al menos una
dosis de la vacuna del cual un 68 por
ciento ya están completamente
inmunizados contra el cob y 19
el fármaco de johnson y johnson tiene un
66% de efectividad y solo requiere una
inyección algo que acelerará la campaña
de inmunización en eeuu
en argentina miles de personas salieron
a las calles de las principales ciudades
este sábado en rechazo al escándalo
conocido como las vacunas vía ipi que
lleva a la renuncia del ministro de
salud tras conocerse de una lista de 70
funcionarios y personalidades que
accedieron a la vacuna contra el cob y
19 de manera irregular la plaza de mayo
en buenos aires fue el epicentro de las
protestas durante las cuales
manifestantes golpearon ollas y sartenes
bajo los demás devuélveme mi vacuna y
las vacunas no deben ser un privilegio
también colgaron bolsas de plástico con
forma de cadáveres para representar a
las víctimas del virus
llamando
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en
y han empezado a vacunar a los amigos
del poder y eso nos corresponde es como
robarle la vida a una persona
la ministra de asuntos exteriores de
españa se encuentra de visita oficial en
colombia para evidenciar el apoyo entre
ambas naciones en materia migratoria
tras su visita a la ciudad de cúcuta
fronteriza con venezuela el presidente
de ese país nicolás maduro ha declarado
que revisará a fondo toda relación con
españa a lo que consideró como una
agresión contra su nación ese es un
informe de rodrigo ciudadano
una agresión por la que revisar a fondo
la relación con españa así describió
nicolás maduró la visita de la ministra
de exteriores española arantxa gonzález
la ya a la ciudad colombiana de cúcuta
principal puerta de llegada de
inmigrantes venezolanos que huyen de la
crisis económica en su país esto después
de que el gobierno venezolano expulsar a
la embajadora de la unión europea
la portuguesa isabel brillante en
respuesta a las sanciones impuestas por
el bloque contra diputados y
funcionarios del gobierno de maduro si
los europeos como estado miembro quieren
reconstruir los puentes con venezuela
saben que siempre nuestro gobierno el
gobierno bolivariano y el estado
venezolano me atrevo a hablar por el
estado venezolano tenderán sus brazos y
sus manos para que efectivamente podamos
hacerlo pero exigimos respeto exigimos
respeto a nuestra constitución nuestras
leyes ya las leyes internacionales la
canciller española expreso que estas
acciones de venezuela no ayudan a
resolver la crisis romper puentes
cortar diálogos y expulsar a nuestros
diplomáticos no ayuda en esa labor de
diálogo yo
modestamente en nuestro país españa
modestamente apuesta por el diálogo para
solucionar también el conflicto político
que existe en venezuela
la visita se encuadra en un viaje de
gonzález lay a colombia en la que ha
mostrado el apoyo de españa el país tras
la creación del estatuto temporal de
protección para los al menos un millón
748 mil migrantes venezolanos que hay en
colombia por su parte el presidente
venezolano nicolás maduro acusó el
sábado al presidente colombiano de usar
a los inmigrantes para justificar los
recursos que solicita organismos
internacionales y que según él terminan
en las mafias
en barcelona continúan las protestas
desatadas por la detención del rapero
pablo hasél este sábado al menos 13
personas fueron detenidas cuando las
manifestaciones derivaron en disturbios
y enfrentamientos con la policía que
cada vez se vuelven más graves más allá
de la liberación del artista ha detenido
el pasado 16 de febrero y acusado de
enaltecimiento al terrorismo
e injuria a la corona los manifestantes
defienden la libertad de expresión
denunciando condiciones laborales
precarias y falta de oportunidades
[Música]
y en hong kong 47 activistas
prodemocracia fueron detenidos
nuevamente tras acusaciones de
conspiración y fomento a la subversión
con base en la polémica ley de seguridad
nacional impuesta por china los
activistas ya habían sido detenidos en
enero pero en esta oportunidad fueron
liberados ahora permanecen detenidos y
ya avanzan los interrogatorios la
policía de hong kong informó mediante un
comunicado que los 47 acusados deberán
comparecer ante un tribunal este lunes
algunos se les confiscaron sus teléfonos
móviles y sus computadoras
así finalizamos por esta emisión pero
ustedes pueden continuar con más de
nuestra programación y también visitar
nuestra página web france24 puntocom nos
vemos más adelante
[Música]